magnus and suddenly black will give some
nasty checks black will make a second
queen of her own
i mean what a position we have right now
how tense is this one if black does take
the time out to make a new queen
okay she doesn't do this then white
would have taken the pawn next to the
black king on the f7 square and i think
that would have ended in checkmate next
move so
black's bishop moving out the way look
at black's queen at the bottom now
guarding the pawn on the f-file but
magnus what a move so calm dodging his
king out the way and now the white
bishop is the one yeah the same diagonal
as the black king he's going to deliver
he's going to deliver the mating blow
four queens on the board though yeah
that's true but it's going to be
checkmate on the same square that uh on
the h8 square and there we go it's a
result checkmate about to happen but
look at this position four queens on the
board what a game between these two
champions wow how would you describe it
four queens on board
it's so rare i think we've seen it maybe
once on last season's tour maybe twice
but
i've never had that position that type
of scenario myself i must admit so what
a game